SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE- HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY. TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I'LL- NOW.
TODAY'S PART NUMBER IS ONE
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO ONE. SIX
THREE SIX FOUR AGAIN THAT
NUMBER IS. ONE EIGHT FOUR FOUR
TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX VOTE
FOR AND THE ACCESS CODE IS NINE
SEVEN FOUR. FIVE EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN ONCE AGAIN THE ACCESS
CODE IS. NINE SEVEN FOUR FIVE
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE AND OR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
COULD BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LIFE
BURKE AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE I
NEEDED ANY WILL THEN READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. NO FIRST
CLEAR. UNTIL A C<c.cyan> FEEDBACK.</c>
NEED TO MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE
Y. THE- FOR. PRIOR TO GIVING
TO. OVER THE FOR. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
WE FOR YOU FOR YOUR- I WILL
MAINTAIN THE CORE. IN THE AS IS
AMERICA. AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO'S- AB RAM REMOVE FROM THE-
ME SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTION SPEED IT. WHAT EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE STREAMLINE
THE HEARING. AND CONDUCT OUR IN
AS CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS
IS BECAUSE- THERE MAY BE SOME
WAY TIME FOR PART. OR JESTING
THE NEW OF TOOLS OR- PLEASE BE.
AND SO ON PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
WE HAVE ONE BILL ON TODAY'S.
FIFTY WE HEAR THE PRESENT ON
THE BILL. LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. ARKANSAS CAN YOU PLEASE
THE ROLL. CALDERON HERE
GALGIANI HERE WILK PRESIDENT
WILK PRESENT COME. COME PRESENT
DOLLY PRESENT VALUE PRESENT
GLAZER. SENATOR GLAZERS THANK
YOU GLAZER. DIFFICULT CANCEL
KNOWS A QUORUM HAS BEEN A- AND
IT IS TIME TO HEAR THE AUTHOR
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMóN HAS
ASKED SENATOR CABDI HERO TO
PRESENT AB TWELVE OH FIVE ON
HER BEHALF WE THINK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR HELPING US MAINTAIN
SOCIAL DISTANCING IS IT. W. YOU
MAY PRESENT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEMOND'S ASSEMBLY BILL. ZERO
FOR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
OPPORTUNITY TO PREVENT AB VOLVO
FIVE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER NAME ON. THIS BILL WILL
SUPPORT THE EVOLUTION OF THE
CALIFORNIA FOR OUR INDUSTRY BY
CODIFYING THE DECISION MADE BY
THE CALIFORNIA CUT FLOWER
COMMISSION. TO REDUCE BOARD
MEMBERSHIP. LIMON TERM. SAN THE
COMMISSION WHICH THIS IN NINETY
THERE'S BEEN A DECREASE AND
NUMBER OF OUR PRODUCERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. HAS RESULT
IT HAS BEEN. COMMITTED TO PAY
TO FILL ALL OF THE POSITIONS ON
BOARD EVEN MORE SO WITH THE
TURN BECAUSE BY TERMINATE.
COULD THIS THE GROUP VOTED TO
REFER ALLEGE PER. REDUCE FOR
MEMBERSHIP AND EMANATE THE
LIMIT TO ENSURE THAT. IT.
DARPA'S. TO RECONVENE THE
COMMISSION SHOULD THE BOARD
VOTE TO DISSOLVE ITSELF IN THE
FUTURE WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE OH FIVE
AND ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS IS
LAUREN NOLAN PROJECT
REPRESENTING THE CUTLER
COMMISSION. WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO ANYONE WANTING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE CHAIRS MAY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. H. PERMITTED AN
EQUAL TO. DETERMINED BY THE
CHAIR ALL OTHERS WISHING TO
TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
NATURE. I BELIEVE WE HAVE ON
THE TELEPHONE LINE LAUREN
MULLEN HEIJI REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CUT FLOWER
COMMISSION MODERATOR CAN WE
PLEASE GET LAUREN ON THE LINE.
LAUREN IS NOT A LOT. LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU AND GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
LEARNED ALL AND HE CHECK ON
BEHALF OF THE ALL OF. OUR
COMMISSION- I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY SENATOR CAFIERO
SAID IT VERY WELL AND EXPLAIN
WHAT THIS IS REALLY ABOUT- AND
THAT CUT FAR INDUSTRY HAD
CHANGED THAT THANK WITH THE
EXCEPTION AND BECAUSE OF THAT
AND THAT THAT THE TAPE. ON SOME
CHANGES FORGET STRUCTURE ALONG
WITH OUR LIMITS ARE GOING TO BE
FURTHER APART THE COMMISSION. I
MADE AT THE END OF TWENTY
ECONOMIC. BANG TO. SOME OTHER
ISSUES BUT THEY WERE LIKE TO
HAVE THE ABILITY TO READ.
THEMSELVES ESTABLISHED AND IN
FUTURE SENATE BILL ALLOWS FOR
THAT PROCEDURE SHOULD THAT TO
DO SO. AGAIN I YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY IN HERE ANSWER ANY
QUESTION I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM HERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO THREE. CNN WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ORBIS.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE
OH FIVE WE WILL BEGIN. PLEASE
JOIN ME ON THE PHONE LINE IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE
OH FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AGAIN ONE ZERO IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT. AT THIS
TIME WE DO HAVE ONE IN OUR
QUEUE. THANK YOU MARK. WE'LL GO
TO LINE OF FOURTEEN NUMBER
FOURTEEN YOUR LINES OPEN. SHARE
MEMBERS ANTHONY MILLION ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
FOR WITH SUFFICIENT IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU. WELL
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
FURTHER IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE MR TO THE MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE CHECK THE LINE
ONCE AGAIN TO BE SURE THAT WE
HAVE HEARD FROM ALL OF THIS OR
WHAT. ON TWELVE. AND IF YOU'RE
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE OH FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU HER FROM ALL
THE SUPPORTERS WILL NOW FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM
ANY OPPOSITION. LET'S MOVE TO
ANY WITNESSES THAT MIGHT BE
HEARING ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE
AND OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SAYING NINE. WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS TO
THE MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION AB TWELVE OH FIVE WE
WILL BEGIN. AND IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWELVE FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AGAIN ONE ZERO HERE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWELVE OH FIVE.
BUT AT THIS TIME WE HAVE KNOWN
IN OPPOSITION TO THE MODERATOR
IF YOU CAN PLEASE CHECK THE
LINE ONE MORE TIME TO BE SURE
WE HAVE HEARD FROM ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES.
ABSOLUTELY ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'RE
IN OPPOSITION. AB TWELVE FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THIS
TIME THERE ARE NONE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE CONTINUE
MADAM CHAIR. TO ALL OF OUR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WITNESSES
WILL NOW BRING THE DISCUSSION
BACK TO THE MEMBERS. AND FOR
OUR REMOTE MEMBER IF YOU WISH
TO ASK A QUESTION. YOU CAN ASK
THE MODERATOR TO OPEN ONLINE
FOR THE FOR YOUR LINE DO ANY OF
OUR MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SENATOR DOLLY THE
BILL. DO WE HAVE WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE BILL DO WE HAVE
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS. I'M
LOOKING TO SENATOR GLAZERS.
CASE. SEVEN NINE WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE BILL. SENATOR
CAVALIER WITH THE LIKE TO CLOSE.
YOU JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE I THINK THIS IS IT
IMMINENT REALLY REASONABLE AND-
DEPRECIATE THAT THE AUTHOR
COMING FORWARD WITH THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SENATOR CAPPIELLO WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL THE
MOVE HAS BEEN FOR THE ARRIVAL
OF THE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO DO
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. GALGIANI I KNOW
JOHNNY AYE WILK HI WILK HI
CABALLERO HI FEBRUARY AYE DADDY.
DAILY I. THAT BILL IS OUT AS
SENATOR THAT I DIDN'T HEAR MY
NAME CALLED- I'M SORRY SORRY
CENTER GLAZER. SENATOR GLAZERS
HI I HAVE A USER BY THANK YOU
SENATOR GLAZERS. THAT BILL IS
OUT THANK YOU TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY
PLEASE SUBMIT COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE OR VISIT
OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO IN YOUR
TESTIMONY. THE OFFICIAL. THANK
YOU AND APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON AGRICULTURE IS ADJOURNED.
THAT MEASURE. YES I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO I THINK THIS IS YOUR
LAST AG COMMITTEE NOW JUST LIKE
TO THANK YOU FOR BEING A GREAT
CHAIR AND REPRESENTING
AGRICULTURE IN A VERY
RESPONSIBLE AND RESPECTFUL WAY
TWINS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE THIS IS SO MUCH SENATOR
DOLLY ENJOYED THIS ROLE AND I'M
VERY PROUD TO REPRESENT OUR OUR
FIFTY PLUS AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY
AND I THINK THAT THIS TIME IN
PARTICULAR. EXPERIENCING ALL OF
THE- FROM THE PROVIDER PANDEMIC
WE REALIZE HOW VERY FORTUNATE
WE ARE THAT WE HAVE SUCH A
ROBUST. DOMESTIC FOOD SUPPLY
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT AS
WE CONTINUE TO DO EVERYTHING
THEY CAN TO ENSURE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE. S. S. FOOD
SUPPLY THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT'S
BEEN AN HONOR.